now joe biden the extreme socialist
democrats continue fueling
reckless radical rhetoric about policing
and continue to needlessly divide the
country
fueling lies about everything from the
georgia voting law
far more accessible than joe's state of
delaware to the non-infrastructure
infrastructure waste of money and of
course blue state bailout
and of course coveted emergency relief
that is anything but
and all this other rhetoric against the
police deep funding and dismantling
because tonight these far left
extremists they are doubling down
they are now firmly backing a corrupt
core packing steam
scheme joe biden now has bought into d.c
statehood which is likely
unconstitutional without an amendment
here's the senate leader mitch mcconnell
slamming it all earlier today take a
look
i've never been one to complain about
fake news but i want to start with the
total frustration i have with the
coverage that most of you have engaged
in with regard
to the issue of expanding the supreme
court i read story
after story after story on this issue
that do not mention
that ruth bader ginsburg and stephen
breyer
the two most important liberals of
modern times are opposed
to court packing so
why don't you include
in these objective analysis of this
issue that fact joining us now senator
lindsey graham from the great state of
south carolina
core packing ending the legislative
filibuster
joe biden now proposing another trillion
dollars
in spending green new green deals
spending
uh i don't think we can afford it i
don't need i don't think i need a math
degree from mit or harvard either to
figure that out um the most radical
agenda i've ever seen in 33 years of
doing this senator
yeah well so his his whole campaign was
a fraud i mean you know he wouldn't
answer the question about do you support
d.c
statehood he wouldn't answer the
question during the campaign about court
packing well we now know
that the agenda coming out of the biden
administration is the most radical
agenda as you said in our lifetime
senator i got to correct you you're
arranging america he was asked and he
said i don't support
any of it none of it core packing ending
the legislative filibuster
yeah so he did say i'll trust you
but yeah yeah i'll trust your research
team
but at best he was unequivocal
i trust you to say that he denied that
he would do these things now why did it
matter
i think a lot of americans would been
unnerved by joe biden if he said
i'm going to make d.c estate because
that dilutes power of the state that you
live in
i think most americans would be upset to
hear that he wanted to change the make
up the supreme court
that would have been a game changer for
a lot of people in terms of how they
vote so
the whole campaign was a fraud but
here's the good news
republicans are not going to let this
happen in the united states senate there
are 50 of us
i'm doing a news conference with uh ted
cruz and a bunch of my colleagues
tomorrow we're going to stand in front
of the supreme court
and we're going to protect the court
we're not going to allow it to go beyond
nine
and we have the power of the 50 of us do
to stop this
they can try to change the filibuster
but if they do that
you need 51 people to pass a bill if all
50 of us say we're not going to show up
on the republican side
all right senator games that leads me to
the million-dollar
question okay i trust you i trust
senator cruz
after hearing mitch mcconnell i believe
he's going to do the right thing too
uh i don't particularly trust mitt
romney or ben
sasse or lisa murkowski are they going
to stand with you or are they going to
allow the democrats to
go forward with the biggest power grab
in the history of the country
well i won't speak for my colleagues i
like them all but i think they
understand that if we give in to this
america will change as we know it
they will destroy the independence of
the judiciary making dc a state is
just an unbelievable power grab hr one
federalizes elections
so tonight here's what i'm asking i'm
asking
every republican senator to come forward
and tell my democratic colleagues our
democratic colleagues
that if you try to change the filibuster
abolish the filibuster
and pass this radical agenda we will use
every tool in the toolbox for us
we will deny you a quorum don't go down
this road
don't blow up the senate don't blow up
the country but republicans need to be
as aggressive as they are
so we have an ability sean to deny them
a quorum by not
simply not showing up i'm willing to do
that as a last-to-ditch effort to stop
the most radical agenda in my lifetime
and every republican senator
i think needs to come forward and let
the democrats know what await them i'll
feel a lot better about that
plan when i hear from sas romney and
murkowski
then i'll feel better about it
yeah well less less ask questions of all
of us all right
senator lindsey graham thank you all
right coming up republicans have